hello reject Nation or should I say oh
reject Nation
[Applause]
we're gonna watch the trailer for Scream
Six today good morning John how are you
I am so excited how are you sir I am
doing great scream is my favorite horror
movie franchise also uh we're just
having a general or take a month we got
a reaction that we're working on for the
movie X at the moment right now it's
just a little difficult to get up on
YouTube considering the kind of content
but we're trying to get it to you guys
by this weekend yeah guys please go
ahead leave a like let us know your
thoughts on the Scream 6 trailer let's
see what's going on I'm excited for it
people
[Music]
problem here guy
love the mats
oh
[Music]
ouch
wow
Ghostface be packing the heat because
his face going hard
it's a tense I didn't I had the secret
there's a Darkness inside of me
yes Sam it followed me here
and it's Gonna Keep Coming For Us
to share a search
ah it's good to see her again it doesn't
like any other ghost face
feels that way
a shrine Dermot Mulroney
we've got a lure him in
we execute him it's the Museum of the
Ghostface or the street movies hello
let's play a game you know you're like
the 10th guy to try this right it never
works out for the [ __ ] and the mask
like me Gail
of course not
oh damn this feels aggressive yeah
different
that's why I'm gonna shoot you in the
head they cut out a swear word
you want me so let's finish this
cool
that's not Tony revolory there let's
just think about it guys
ready
oh Mindy
wow yeah that was intense that went hard
that's cool that was great that looks
great that feels so different refreshing
and you know with like New York City
being you know kind of like such an
aggressive kind of City it really feels
like it's capturing that intensity of
what it's like out there in a weird way
so what I like about it is more than
just switching up the franchise to give
you a different location it's really
taking on the spirit and the energy of
you know moving it over to there just
kind of wasn't expecting you know like
there are parts of this that kind of
remind me of a shades of the Halloween
uh reboot um the the ones that have been
out recently because of the level of
force that this this trailer has such an
impact on they really capture the the
tension of course I'm excited for like
returning Legacy characters like Kirby
and and yeah it's like this I have no
idea what Kirby's up to you're getting
like Kirby and Mindy in here which are
they're very very kind similar yes
you're going to have a lot of horror
based bantering a lot of movies being
shot back and forth between the two most
likely yeah it didn't I didn't quite get
a sense for because you know like scream
five was such a a commentary on on soft
reboots but I didn't really get a sense
on what the commentary for for here
would be this really focused on the
immediacy and the visceral quality like
this this has taken itself very serious
and I liked it because I was really
buying into even the moment with Gail
like damn they might actually kill her
off this time like I really I really
believed in here that they could do it
they might they might actually kill her
off yeah there's something innately
threatening about the way that they've
chosen to portray all this and I think
that's good because I think of all these
characters you assume that the Legacy
ones will be the safest ones and I
wonder too if that will be part of the
meta angle this movie is taking with you
know the deeper you get into a franchise
the more Legacy and the more sort of the
new era versus the old era becomes part
of the major debate about whatever you
know having this Museum of ghost face
artifacts and stuff like that and I
wonder if uh yeah that will inform the
metageness that they're going for but
yeah I really liked the way that this
kind of embodied like this reminded me
of the Way That 80s horror movies
especially have this New York that feels
like just the worst most dangerous
Lawless place and this doesn't feel like
quite as stylized as that but it does
feel like it's borrowing some of that
aesthetic and some of that just
underlying sleazy grit to inform you
know the the change in scenery I'm
wondering too how much they're going to
you know really go Hog Wild with uh you
know tributing the various horror films
that have taken place in New York Beyond
Jason Takes Manhattan and stuff like
that but you know like your Maniac type
movies and and other things well when
looking at this Museum uh that I'm
recognizing so many different uh
costumes sure from other characters who
are no longer with us but then you've
also got material from stab in the
corner here I'm curious if this one in
particular just because of sort of the
rawness to this trailer how it looks
like they'll be carrying on the the
themes of trauma especially with the
carpenter sisters yeah how much of my
deal with like True Crime sensationalism
because the you know in the world of
scream these Ghost Face killings really
happen and then they got adapted into a
a franchise that has just become the
stab franchise which you know is taking
advantage of real life tragedies and now
they have like a museum dedicated to it
where you can have like Fanfare and
stuff while you got real life victims
walking about you know and then like
they're parading around on Halloween
costumes wearing the ghost face mask and
such they haven't really done that and I
know that with things like the the
Dahmer show that came out how that even
after Evan peters's win how that became
such a discussion I have no clue if this
is the route that gonna they're gonna go
down but there's there's a bit of an
impression that I'm getting here it'd be
kind of cool it'd be different every
screen because this feels different I
mean if there's one thing I can totally
give this particular trailer credit for
was I remember watching even I like the
the last Scream movie I wasn't in love
with it like most people were but I
remember even watching that trailer and
being like yeah I'm not really sure
what's different about this one though
but this one there's just it does hit us
oh they're they're doing different [ __ ]
with this one yeah yeah like you that
that really hits home here like even the
way that the scene like ghost station
with the shotgun actually speaks a lot
of volumes yeah and obviously he didn't
like walk in you know uh rocket he took
it off the person the fact that he just
kind of like went around with it you
know yeah yeah this ghost face has a
different more sort of cut throat
sensibility rather than like it still
seems like Ghostface is going to be a
character who ghost faces at least it
has to be but but yeah that like you
know Ghostface loves to play with his
food and I get the sense from this one
that there is yeah just like more latent
rage under there and two well there's
tomorrow evening sorry John yeah I heard
she was going to be in here yeah
absolutely yeah but I wonder too if
that's going to be like the original
ghost face mask or something like that
because they've gone out of their way to
make it look so aged and and Haggard and
whatnot so I wonder too with the Billy
Loomis Connection in here if they're
gonna you know further that sort of uh
you know the the fantastical
well it was stew and Billy right yeah
yes but you know like one of the two
original masks or whatever because uh
Sam has that you know connection to
Billy looks like Minnie's got a
girlfriend yeah
woke scream
no man this looks great uh I was I was
thoroughly impressed with this trailer I
was I'm surprised by how impressed this
was an awesome one this was a really
really awesome trailer and I can't wait
to see this movie yeah um I feel like I
feel like this is going to be something
um pretty rad actually yeah alrighty
guys well thank you so much for being
here be sure to leave a like uh
subscribe let us know your thoughts on
the trailer down below and hey let's end
this with a
Daniel Gallagher Daniel my friend it
looks like you actually had a pretty
successful 2022 I follow you on Facebook
I see the love that you're parading
around with that hot hot woman
she's so hot Daniel dude congratulations
on on a snag at a hot one that's right
I don't even care if her personality is
boring you've won that doesn't matter
especially if you live in Scotland
achievement unlocked you have got down
the most important quality of any loving
relationship true true the hotness yes
yes so congrats to you on that man
because if you got that that lasts
forever so you just make sure to keep
her happy
keep her hot and you stay hot to match
her hotness and just know that if if you
feel insecure like oh man I got such a
hot girlfriend and uh it's making now
I'm now I feel like I gotta take out my
J my my insecurities on her
just know totally normal and it happens
all the time and I encourage him I
encourage it very much so yeah and
you're Scottish so
you you've it's expected yeah
anyway thanks for being part of our
patreon page and I hope you have a great
2023.
[Music]